Joe Scarborough Scarborough who will
always take every position on everything
we've shown many videos of that in the
past and what's he mocking is he mocking
the people that are coming after your
gas stove the people who want to cook
the way we've cooked for a long time and
you have a right to use gas and that
these idiots think that they can somehow
make as they don't even know where
electricity comes from it's also stupid
but here's Joe Scarborough instead of
Defending individual rights instead of
defending the autonomy of the United
States and our ability to cook as we
please uh he's upset with the
Republicans who are making a big deal
about it
oh my God oh my God oh my God this is
this is this is an issue that that you
you you you you look and you want to see
how politics gets crazy you get one side
gets like
a small kernel
of something half a kernel and they put
in the ground and they water it water
try to get it to grow and and so this
gas stove thing
you get some bureaucrats saying
something that has no power and then
suddenly
you have Rhonda Sanders so I'm going to
protect your guests everybody talking
about gas stoves gas it's yeah you smug
douche Rhonda said this is going to
protect our gas stoves he's already uh
talked about how we're going to keep
that [ __ ] going right here in Florida
Joe Scarborough is worth 25 million
dollars I I don't begrudge anyone making
money I really do not I don't like when
charlatans and obvious grifters
um make a lot of money but I don't
begrudge him the 25 million and that's
his wife by the way he started banging
his co-host a couple years ago and then
they got married to their credit uh
that's Mika Brzezinski and she's worth
about 20 million so they're worth about
50 million together if you think for one
second that they are going to give up
their gas stove and they are going to
give up their cars or whatever else like
you're an NPC but I know you don't think
that because you're watching this show
but these people you see how they're
aiming the wrong way people want to come
for more of your freedoms they want to
come for more of your stuff and their
corporate he is a corporate hack
his job is to mock the people who will
defend the freedoms
[Music]